das bizarre an der situation ist
bezahlen tun wir das wenn wir bei uns
tanken fahren wenn wir in bayern bei
bayern
sprit tanken oder hier den rasen jetzt
sprit den der aus der der aus schwedt
kommt wenn wir gas wenn wir mit der
gastherme heizen wenn wir wenn wir
kochen zahlen wir demnächst den preis
für diesen krieg putin verdient sich
daran eine goldene nase einfach weil
jetzt die ölpreise hoch gehen die
gaspreise hoch hoch gehen bei uns sind
die gasspeicher leer wir haben
zugelassen dass die gasspeicher bei uns
seinen konzern gehören dass die größten
gasspeicher deutschland die
niedersachsen sind das die gazprom
gehören und wir zahlen jetzt diesen
preis 55 prozent des erdgases in
deutschland kommt von gazprom muss man
sagen die bundesregierung hat gestern
gesagt wirtschaftsminister robert habeck
dass die reserven auch wenn die
erdgaslieferung aus russland jetzt
sozusagen im gegenzug zu sanktionen
gekappt werden würden die reserven noch
für diesen winter reichen würde weil man
sich flüssiggas von woanders besorgen
könnte das ist danach aber dann auch
knapp werden kann ja und ist mag hier
erreichen aber das was da ist wird der
teure einfach weil die preise steigen
das ist das bizarre wir bezahlen putins
krieg das ist das ergebnis unserer
wirklich fast totalen abhängigkeit vom
russischen von russischen
energielieferungen von öl und von gas
das haben uns namentlich das kann man
einfach mal so klappen denn zwei
bundeskanzler nacheinander eingebrockt
das war gerhard schröder mit seiner
merkwürdigen komischen klandestinen
männerfreundschaft mit wladimir putin
hat noch im amt dafür gesorgt dass noten
eins kommen kann er hat noch immer
sitzen milliarden euro schulden für
russland einfach erlassen in seinen
letzten tagen unter einem
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die uns in
der energiewende so bunt wie die gemeint
ist da kann man zu stehen wie man will
aber das ergebnis ist dass die
abhängigkeit von russland im
rohstoffsektor einfach dramatisch
angestiegen ist und dafür zahlen wir den
preis und wer in deutschland meint dass
ihm dieser konflikt in der ukraine
nichts angeht dass das ganz weit weg ist
spätestens anderthalb sollte spätestens
am gasherd weiß man eigentlich wir
zahlen dem den wind den preis die
energiekosten werden jetzt um 30 bis 70
prozent steigen und das ist das ergebnis
davon und es fühlt nur einem mann die
kasse und das ist laut putin